I have let good people stand accused of
things that I've done
Roy Harper is not the green arrow Tommy
Merlyn is most certainly not the green
arrow truth is I am Iron Man
hey everybody is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow finale video they finally
did all the things that we've been
expecting them to do for the last couple
of seasons and teed up a really big
villain group that we've been expecting
ever since we found out that richard
dragon was going to be the season 6
villain like are they gonna do longbow
hunters well now we know they are
definitely doing longbow hunters but
they've been sitting on it all season
long we got all those cameos to talk
about and more Batwoman inside the arrow
verse so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
the DC videos there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway going on - I'll name
a winner at the end of this but there's
just a lot of DC stuff happening this
summer and it's only getting started so
even though all the finales are
happening right now there's still gonna
be a lot of stuff happening really soon
but instead of doing this top 10 style
I'm just gonna go down like the really
big things that they did there are a
couple big turns and a couple big things
that they were setting up so obviously
the biggest thing is him having his I am
Iron Man moment it felt like there were
a couple of key moments along the way
the last six seasons where they were
building towards this reveal and then
they would pull back Marc Guggenheim the
old showrunner is departing he talked
about them using this is their
penultimate card to play in like the big
cars that you play like oh my god your
father has a list he was secretly a
criminal with these other people was a
big card they played during the first
season there are a couple big moments in
the life of the show that they can drop
and have it changed the direction of the
show going forward like things will
never be the same after this moment
meaning there's still one big card to
play going out which i think is really
just the city accepting all of her
knowing exactly who he is like oh you're
the Green Arrow even though we demonized
you for the first six seasons but there
are some heroes like Batman or the flash
that will probably never publicly
release their identity like Iron Man did
this in the Iron Man movie ten years ago
that's how long ago this moment was but
it's just a thing that some heroes will
never reveal their full identity but
you'll probably never
a moment on screen where Superman in
front of a bunch of cameras in the world
says I have been Clark Kent this whole
time so obviously Oliver's going to
Supermax now the title of the finale was
life sentence it's implied that he's
serving a life sentence in exchange for
immunity for the rest of the group there
were two big Easter eggs in that so they
called it the slab but they also call it
Supermax so there's that Green Arrow
Super Max movie that didn't get made
from the early 2000s I think I talked
about that in a previous video but the
whole idea for that movie when they were
originally intending on making it was
Oliver Queen being falsely imprisoned in
having to break out of Supermax filled
with C and d-list villains from the DC
Universe so that's what they might do
for the first half of arrow season 7 so
think of it is a more hardcore version
of iron Heights that Barry went to
during season four of the flash so if
you ever saw HBO's Oz or you saw
Shawshank I feel like everybody has seen
a little bit of Shawshank even if you
haven't seen the whole movie it's gonna
be more like that arrow is way more
hardcore with the way it treats stuff
like that than the flash is but when
they actually said the name of the Super
Max prison the slab
you may recognize that as slab side
prison which is a big DC Comics prison
the warden was actually the third
version of mr. miracle so I'm wondering
how many comic book Easter eggs we're
gonna find in here in how many episodes
were gonna spend with Oliver in prison
because they teased the villains for the
first part of arrow season 7 at least
are going to be Diaz with the longbow
hunters it feels like what they'll do is
they'll have Oliver either take down
Diaz the first half of the season
that'll be him slowly getting out of
prison by the mid-season finale taking
down Diaz and what they might do is
they'll either have him take down the
longbow hunters in the mid-season finale
and tee up some other arc or they'll use
the longbow hunters as the main villains
of season 7 or they'll treat Diaz more
like they treated Kaden James during
season 6 we're like he's a front for
something bigger the bigger thing being
the longbow hunters there were a couple
lines of dialogue where they were very
clearly foreshadowing the way they were
gonna be using longbow hunters and how
they wanted you to frame them compared
to some of the other villains and
organizations we've seen in the past
they say oh wow
there's three of them they
supposedly died off in the 1950s but
very clearly that's not true if Diaz is
going to them now they're so badass that
apparently the League of Assassins is
afraid of them so they just framed them
as a smaller but more deadly group of
people so I think they have potential to
be the main villains but I think the
real reaction that everybody got was as
why have we waited this long to do
longbow hunters because the longbow
hunters is one of the most famous Green
Arrow stories of all time in shadow for
instance that we did in the first couple
of seasons she was a member of the
longbow hunters in the comics but that
arc actually took place in Seattle it
was this really seminal Green Arrow
Black Canary story where they moved to
Seattle they encountered the longbow
hunters but depending on how they treat
them during season seven we can talk
about comic book Easter eggs but if you
want to read that story I would
recommend you check it out it's actually
pretty good several years ago when DC
had its big new 52 reboot Richard Dragon
was a big new 52 villain but he had an
evil team around him but they were
called the longbow hunters it was count
vertigo brick-red dart and Killer Moth
so because they've already done a couple
of these characters they've already done
count vertigo twice two different
versions they've already done brick
they're gonna have to cycle the villains
a little bit but my hope is is that they
will be recognizable villains from the
DC Universe we obviously got to talk
about that Quentin death I think we knew
he was leaving the show a couple months
ago so it was a pretty safe bet that he
was gonna die but I think they did a
pretty good job with all the goodbyes
they gave him he had that really nice
moment with Oliver where Oliver almost
called him his second dad then obviously
you could see how they're using it for
black sirens Redemption arc and then you
have Sarah coming in it is them sort of
paying off a lot of arcs from earlier in
the season like you have black siren
that you're bringing into the universe
so they spent a lot of time trying to
address whether or not she was like the
original version of Laurel and how the
characters felt about that so the last
big part of that wasn't having Sarah
finally come and acknowledge her
existence are you like my Laurel no not
at all okay great so I was a little
disappointed with the amount of Sarah
that we got in the finale like she just
showed up for a couple minutes but that
speech at the end where he has his Iron
Man moment specifically calls out Tommy
and Roy but we know that Roy is coming
back in season 7 so this is all
just sort of like clearing the air so
that nobody tries to arrest Roy the
minute he steps out in public the reason
why they gave Diggle his own version of
the costume is because they want to open
season 7 with him on the streets taking
down bills they want a green arrow in
the city even though Oliver is in
Supermax I will say that I love David
Ramsey
I love the Diggle character but I have
zero interest and seeing him as the
green arrow so I'm wondering how
temporary this is since they've
announced Batwoman is coming to the
arrowverse a lot of you are like is this
going to replace arrow as a TV show when
it goes off the air I think there's
potential for a Batwoman TV show but I
don't think that anyone is clamoring for
it right now so I think it just depends
on how things go when they introduce her
on the show because originally the whole
idea for legends of tomorrow was that it
was going to be a spin-off show based on
the Hawks and that ended up being
terrible the worst idea ever so I will
say right now I would much rather than
just use the Batwoman character in a
couple of really awesome appearances
rather than try and shoehorn her into a
show with 23 episodes with a whole bunch
of filler in not doing any of the big
comic-book stories that you really want
them to do because they don't have
access to all the Batman characters
because some of them are film only
there's just a lot of problems when you
try to do a Batman based TV show when
you don't have access to the characters
that you need so don't hold your breath
for a Batwoman TV show but that does
feel like something that the CW as a
network would go for she's an LGBT
superhero so she checks out pretty much
every box that the CW is looking for
every time I see footage for a new CW TV
show I think about that cat grant
comment from the Supergirl crossover all
four of you standing there doing nothing
you look like the attractive yet
non-threatening racially diverse cast of
a CW show so everybody let me know in
the comments what did you think about
the finale and what do you think about
the stuff that they're teasing for
season 7 what'll happen is is later
today I'll post my spoiler Deadpool to
review and then I'll be posting Easter
eggs over the weekend there's some new
flash footage for the finale that I'll
post this weekend too congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner super cool
please private message me so I can get
your contact details on a Manu winner
when I post new DC
so while you wait for everything click
here for my Deadpool to post credit
scene video and click here for my flash
finale trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight